si tu dis oui c'est une [ __ ] si tu dis
non c'est une [ __ ] sont surtout ces
gens là
je sors bien le trouver
façon à vis des musulmans et va me
respectent et desservi et fait parti des
frères musulmans
quoi de plus le frère mutz frère je
m'amuse voilà à la dire le rappel
profiter aux croyants alors je te
rappelle chouf avant d'ouvrir ta grande
gueule à la [ __ ] partie se situe coché
toutes les cases sauf musulman marié
pour pas qu'ils soient collant tue pas
en cacahouète part en couille et les
musulmans alors sa compagne ça
non
demande si jamais les sucettes essaye de
mule qu'elles n'ont pas de brosse à
dents
voilà attaquer c'est quoi la taille
veston chypre c'est une métaphore filée
pour dire tout engin tu avec yasser
arafat
ça va ouais ça va et va pas aller chez
toi tu es bush va tuer la juge
tu as pris par terre vous avez fait quoi
vous êtes vous l'avez fait comment
[ __ ] tu es heureux car quand je te
parles tu me regardes quoi je te parles
tu me regarde pas je te vois
ah [ __ ] regarde pas si mon cas là tu
as gardé son sens grossistes